bonjour mathieu courjault vous êtes
paysans en vendée porte parole du
collectif nous produisons nous mangeons
nous décidons a tout d'abord avant de
parler de votre de vos propositions
quelles peuvent être les conséquences
pour les agriculteurs français de la
guerre en cours qui a évoqué ce matin
sur place au salon de l'agriculture le
chef de l'état bien les conséquences
peuvent être graves peuvent être graves
à plusieurs titres d'abord sur le prix
de l'essence a comme tous les français
où l'agriculture consomme de l'essence
et donc il va y avoir des répercussions
des répercussions aussi car
l'agriculture utilise beaucoup d'engrais
chimiques l'engrais chimique qui est
dépendant du gaz russe pour savoir de
fabrication qu'à un quart des engrais
chimique en france qui sont faits à
partir du
qui sont importés de russie donc là
c'est extrêmement grave et là dessus on
a eu un vrai élément important qui est
de dire mais il faut que l'agriculture
on aurait dû faire des choix politiques
importants pour que la france soit moins
dépendants du gaz russe moins dépendant
des engrais chimiques donc là on a un
certain nombre de propositions pour
aller dans ce sens la suffisance son
loto c'est fini dans ces débats aussi on
a des systèmes agricoles qui sont
beaucoup moins dépendants des engrais
chimiques l'agriculture biologique par
exemple n'utilise pas d'engrais
chimiques donc on voit bien que on a des
modèles de production agricole qu'il
faut encourager qui sont plus autonome
pour être moins dépendant de toutes ces
perturbations internationales
par ailleurs christiane lambert la
présidente de la fnsea lance un appelle
justement une action de solidarité pour
aider les ukrainiens comme on peut se
traduire d'après vous cet appel est bien
effectivement je crois que il faut pas
se tromper les premières victimes ce
sont bien les ukrainiens les
ukrainiennes de cette guerre alors après
je ne sais pas comment ça peut se
traduire la solidarité mais ce qui est
clair c'est que il va y avoir besoin je
pense que les agriculteurs l'abord en
ukraine sont effectivement très pénalisé
donc il va falloir les accompagner etc
etc que représente pour en venir à vous
maintenant que représente ce collectif
et que vous voulez que voulez-vous dire
lorsque vous parlez d'une nouvelle voie
en fait nous ce qu'on ce qu'on veut dire
c'est qu'on représente 10 millions de
françaises des millions de français qui
pensent qu'une autre agriculture est
possible qu'une agriculture qui rémunère
correctement les paysans une agriculture
qui combat qui lutte contre le
changement climatique qui luttent contre
la caisse de la biodiversité en
réduisant ses impacts une agriculture
qui chercha à promouvoir aussi à
garantir le droit à une alimentation de
qualité pour toutes et tous et donc le
souci c'est que aujourd'hui ses citoyens
cette majorité silencieuse en fait on
les entend pas on les entend pas les
candidats la candidate à la
présidentielle les entendent pas
suffisamment parce qu'on les écoute pas
et donc nous c'est vraiment ce qu'on a
voulu faire de rassembler des paysans de
rassembler des consommateurs pour
travailler ensemble pour construire
ensemble un autre projet de politique
agricole et alimentaire et dans cette
nouvelle voie quelle est votre position
sur l' usage des pesticides dont on
vient d'apprendre à potable après des
enquêtes récentes que les agriculteurs
sont les premières victimes mais
effectivement les agriculteurs sont les
premières victimes des pesticides je
crois que c'est très important de le
rappeler nous collectivement se comporte
c'est la sortie des pesticides de
synthèse donc ça c'est voilà c'est une
position qui est très clair au sein de
35 organisations et donc ça va être un
peu compliqué parce que les pesticides
est effectivement les agriculteurs sont
victimes avec différentes maladies
maladie de parkinson maladie de la
prostate
donc il ya un besoin d'un changement il
ya besoin d'un changement politique
d'accompagnement on a beaucoup
d'humilité pour une réforme de la
politique agricole commune parce qu il
ya des modèles agricoles on sait faire
aujourd'hui pour se passer de pesticides
ou pour tout au moins en diminuer
largement l'utilisation et aujourd'hui
on a besoin d'accompagner des adducteurs
donner les moyens aux agriculteurs est
ce que le gouvernement n'a pas assez
fait dans la dernière réforme de la
politique agricole commune par exemple
quelles sont par exemple est-ce que vos
préconisations produire local et
consommer local alors oui bien sûr que
ça fait partie de nos préconisations et
de relocaliser au maximum on voit bien
que sur la crise du crédit est une autre
conséquence dont je n'ai pas parlé c'est
effectivement le délai toutes les
conséquences sur le marché des céréales
où on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans un système un peu fou où ce qui se
passe en russie en ukraine qui en
annexant le l'ukraine la russie va
contrôler quasiment le tiers des
exportations mondiales de céréales donc
c'est quand même très conséquent et ça
va avoir des répercussions directement
pour les producteurs de porcs de
volailles chez nous donc on voit bien
qu'on est dans un système où le profit
qui est fait sur les sur les échanges
commerciaux sur les produits agricoles
les produits alimentaires en fait ça
faut pas fonctionné et donc on voit bien
qu'on voit aussi de crise en crise pour
le monde agricole et donc il va bien
falloir un moment prendre le courage de
prendre les bonnes décisions pour
justement aller vers une culture
beaucoup plus autonome beaucoup plus
économes sur pour les territoires quels
sont les obstacles les obstacles à la
mise en oeuvre de cette nouvelle voie
les oblats client n'a pas parce que
techniquement on sait faire l'obstacle
majeur il est sur le courage politique
est ce que on va avoir quelqu'un au
président une présidente quand le
courage politique d'affronter
correctement le lobby de l'agrobusiness
pour le dire pour le dire simplement et
d'aller au bout pour donner les moyens
aux agriculteurs la culture de faire
évoluer leurs pratiques de changer le
tout dans ceci avec des règles
commerciales qui va falloir aussi faire
évoluer parce que nous sommes à 40 jours
là du premier tour d'élection
présidentielle quel bilan vous tirez
vous de la politique agricole suivi par
le chef de l'état emmanuel macron et
bien un bilan plutôt négatif c'est à
dire qu'on est une première partie de
quinquennat qui était plutôt
intéressante où on voit bien qu'avec le
lancement des états généraux de
l'alimentation n'a eu quand même
l'impression que à la fois les
changements de modèles la transition à
dreux écologique est aussi le le revenu
des paysans étaient vraiment quelque
chose qui sera au coeur de la future
politique agricole du gouvernement donc
ça on était plutôt content après on voit
bien qu'on a eu un retour en force du
conservatisme agricole où on a mis on a
remis sur pied les nouveaux ogm la
robotisation la numérisation plutôt sept
fils cette fuite en avant technologique
qui clairement clairement nous ne nous
posent souci donc on a bien vu aussi
avec la réforme de la politique agricole
commune que clairement ben voilà il n'y
avait aucune envie de changer et donc ça
c'est un vrai regret qu'on a sur cette
deuxième partie de quinquennat